Cindy is a clothing brand that as you
know we're boycotting Israeli products.
Go to cindy.com. Why? I've been wearing
the products for years, for 6 7 8 years.
From training, gym, boxing, jogging,
praying, covers your aura, it's an extra
long cover for our sisters, and even
women's wear. I urge you guys to check
them out. They've got beautiful
beautiful clothing. They have amazing
clothes from them inshallah brothers and
sisters. You can see for yourself with
variety of amazing amazing clothing
brothers and sisters that are suitable
for all ages and both genders inshallah.
Enjoy the video. As-salamu alaykum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh brothers and
sisters and dear friends. So, this has
been happening a couple of days ago. I
wanted to make a commentary on it and
subhanallah I got a chance to do it now.
Before I go into the video inshallah
brothers and sisters and see the reply
of Mishary, what he actually said, what
this means, is he a munafiq? Audhu
billahi whatever whatever whatever. For
that matter we're going to look at this
in in a balanced way because there are
two extremes in this. Before that though
guys, we have started a brand new
episode, a brand new podcast called
Let's Play Game. It's a card game and we
have different guests from all kind of
backgrounds. Those speakers that you
love to hear, you're speaking about
Sufyan ibn Nayem ibn Roberts, Suboor
Ahmed, and Suhaib Webb. Have you or
someone you know resorted to magic to
solve an issue because they were very
desperate?
Mhm. And fourth episode is with Mohammed
Hijab. So, subscribe to that inshallah
channel. It's an amazing podcast with
card games, interesting, thrilling
inshallah, and keeps the guest on edge.
Now, let's get straight into it. So,
what was the post that Mishary done and
why is he in this mess? Let's dissect it
and look into it. Mishary I thought he
was from Saudi origin. You know he's
Kuwaiti. Alhamdulillah. May Allah bless
and protect
our brothers and sisters in Kuwait and
all around the Gulf region. Subhanallah
of course the attacks and war is
happening. So, he said the following.
So, here's a Quran verse that everyone
knows. They're not they're very familiar
with them. White House President Trump
will open the gates of hell on Iran.
There is problems with that and of
course nobody can deny that subhanallah
the fact that he's like President Trump.
Okay, he's not someone that should be
even called like I I'll call him a
Trump. Okay? So, he's not someone that
should be given that title or that
respect. So, the problem I think many
people had was why would someone who's a
Quran reciter, somebody who recites the
Kalam of Allah, align himself with
someone as violent as that? Now, this is
where I say, brothers and sisters, we
have to be a bit balanced, okay? There
are things that might seem
apparent from the apparent when you say,
"Hold on a second." Like Allah in the
Quran tells us, or the Prophet
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam, when a
companion came and said that he um
killed a man in the battlefield, and he
said, "Why?" The Prophet Sallallahu
Alaihi Wasallam said, "Why did you kill
him?" He said, "Because I was about to
strike him, and he said uh I believe" He
said the Shahada. He said the Shahada.
And he said, "I know he was doing that
out of fear." The Prophet Sallallahu
Alaihi Wasallam got angry. He said, "Did
you open his heart to see that he was
doing it because of this?" We need to
put things in the context and
perspective, okay? Why? Because if we go
to another post of his, brothers and
sisters, okay? This is a a bit of a
context of someone who prayed behind
him, someone called Shuaib. A lot of you
don't realize this is This is personal
for Sheikh Mishary. I was praying behind
him the other day when Iran was sending
drones above the masjid during Tarawih.
Deep that That's That's how spineless
they are. Okay. But then there's context
of what Iran is doing and the and the
how they're justifying it. And then
we're going to come to what Iran has
done to the Sunni Muslims as well for us
to be strategically consistent. And now
I can speak about it. Nobody can come
and tell me that I'm a bootlicker or
this that. With all due respect,
alhamdulillah, my reputation speaks for
itself.
Now, somebody else came and said,
"Quran.com removes Mishary Alafasy as uh
Al Alafasy as default reciter across the
site."
This is an important step as Quran
should be associated with someone who
provides religious cover for tyrants and
oppressors. Our digital space must
reflect values of Islam, not treacherous
politics. Again, that's his perspective
on the matter. Now, here is a post that
was made by Mishary on um
on March the 10th. "Oh God, bring down
upon the Brotherhood and the Zionist and
Iran and all who side with them from the
traitors to the Arabs and the
homelands." So, he firstly thinks in the
perspective, we cannot come and because
of a statement he made, go to the other
extreme here, he's a munafiq, he's a
kafir, he's this. Number one, this is
this is a major sin because you are
doing takfir. Number That statement
doesn't take him out of Islam. You can't
call him this or that etc. because you
need to understand there are innocents
also, not saying Iran targets on purpose
or not, but they are targeting airports.
When I was on my way to Mecca, airports
were closed in different not in Jeddah
but other airports where innocent
people's lives were being affected. Now,
are those Saudis going to love Iran or
hate Iran? Now, the same can be said
against those in Iran cuz we need to be
just and fair. Yes, I believe the Shia
Muslims are Muslims except the Rafidah
are what kufar. Okay, who insult the
prophet and his wives.
Insult the prophet's wives and
companions. So, they are saying 180
Iranian girls got massacred. And that's
a reality bro. I'm not going to come
here and be like a Zionist and be like,
oh they justified it. We need to break
this down guys.
180 innocent girls in Iran was were
massacred.
Children, kids.
I don't care if they're Shia or Rafidah.
Kids, I do not care. They are children.
Because if I distinguish and said, yeah,
but no cuz of this, what's the
difference between me and you and the
Zionist? What's the difference if we
want the same thing? Let me tell you
something. When I see Zionist children
who are brainwashed who say that the
Zionist
you know, they're saying that there
should be a genocide, I condemn that.
Because they are not my teacher. Allah
and his messenger is my teacher. So,
when you put into perspective everyone
from each side are justified. They are
justified. But we need to also
perspective which we're going to come to
and also Dede Hussein has covered it in
five pillars as well which we're going
to come to before we come to Ammar
al-Shalabi's
reply.
Iran
has killed more Muslims
than
Zionists.
If you have a problem with this
statement, you are like a Zionist. Why?
Because in order for us to be morally
consistent, we have to condemn whoever's
doing the doing the killing. Russia,
China, Iran, Israel, America, whichever
government Muslim government
you can't come and say that's okay
because then what makes you from you the
different from Zionists?
Iran has killed nearly half a million
Sunni Muslims in Syria.
Don't forget that.
However,
when it comes to this war, do we align
ourselves with the Zionists? No. We
align ourselves with Iran and I've made
this very clear and I'm proud to say
this. I don't go to other extremes where
it's like Iran is No, no, no, no.
When it comes to Iran and Israel, Iran
and Israel,
we say we are at the on the side of
those who are attacking those genocidal
maniacs. We are being consistent in
that. Okay? But we also do not come and
say Iran can come and attack civilian
infrastructure and attack civilians. No.
Iran doesn't do that. But when the
missiles unintentionally fall there,
which genuinely unintentionally fall
there, we say, "Okay." For that matter,
"Okay, as long as it's not targeting
civilians on purpose."
This is what we need to understand. And
you need to understand in these Gulf
countries, yes, then it's the situation
of um the why are the Muslim lands
hosting these air bases? Well, you need
to understand that there is, if you
think about protection money being paid
because at the end of the day they see
Iran as a threat that would want to come
and take over, etc. We know Iran's proxy
wars. There's so much politics I don't
want to get into that I don't even know
about. It's not even my area. I want to
stick to my lane. I'm just saying from a
perspective where you're like, "Okay,
they're doing this because they fear
Iran and they're like, "Who else can we
trust? Who's the daddy of the earth
today? It's America. They have powers,
etc. whatever." So, they're like, "We
need to align ourselves with them cuz
Iran is an enemy to us and rah-di rah-di
rah-di rah." Now, this is why we need to
be careful and can't label Mishary as a
munafiq. No, no, no. He It's wrong for
him to Trump Who the hell is Trump? He's
wrong. I've I'm saying that was
absolutely wrong. He should not say
that. However, then to make him a
munafiq and kafir is not correct. What
is what Dilly Five Pillars are saying.
World Kuwaiti Quran reciter Mishary
Rashid Alafasy has been forced to issue
a statement following widespread outrage
over a recent pro-war expose that
exposed support for the US war on Iran.
Alafasy originally posted a statement on
his official X account 2 days ago
ago in while he backed Donald Trump
threat to open the gates of hell on
Iran. I mean claims he is expressing
support for Israel's war on the Muslim
world. Alafasy
Alafasy I don't know how to pronounce
his name. Forget him. Mishary has now
clarified his stance stating that he's
not pro Israel because he's defending
his his nation.
That's true. You cannot come and say,
"Look, I'm against Iran." What does that
What does that mean? I'm pro-Zionist
now. Please get out of here. So, we
cannot come and say he's this, he's
that. No, he's angry that his country's
being attacked. Now, he can look Look,
this is a government issue. He can say,
"Look, I'm not the government. I'm
fearful of my family, etc." Whatever it
is for that matter. But again, if you
think about it, Donald Trump what did
not Donald Trump
Jordan Peterson what did he say? Unleash
hell on them, the cousins. So, it's the
And who you're aligning yourself with is
probably not so I believe it was a wrong
tweet for him. He could have come and
say
"May Iran May Allah deal with Iran for
what it's doing to my country."
Whatever.
But when you
quote a Iblis
like Trump, that is the issue that he
made. So, So, he said, "The coordinated
campaign against me orchestrated from
abroad and conducted in English is clear
in its false motives. Its tools and its
methods are evident and the and the
response of pro-Iran and pro-brotherhood
voices along with
along with their insults reveal their
retaliatory motives. None of this will
deter me from my firm stance in
defending my country and the Gulf states
and in rejecting the aggressive Iranian
attacks that target the Gulf more than
they target Israel. I have made this
clear multiple posts that oppressing
opposing the aggression does not mean I
am siding with Israel. We also reject
aggression against Palestine and Gaza."
So, that is fair, guys. You cannot come
and say "Oh, because he said that, he's
aligning with Israel." No, it doesn't
mean just because like me calling out
Iran and what he did what they did to
Sunni Muslims in Syria means I'm
aligning with Zionist. Okay, there's
some brothers out there who call you
know people you know
Mossad agents and rabbis and this etc.
I'm so sorry, that's another extreme.
You cannot come. You have to be
consistent and call out Iran as much as
you call out them. So subhanallah you
have to be consistent. So I would say in
a nutshell guys, would I stop listening
to him? I would say what he says was
distasteful. May Allah forgive him. It
was a mistake. Yes, he had concerns for
his country and whatever if the person
who prayed in the masjid saying there
was drones and they start over the
masjid or whatever it is for that
matter. He fears from his family and his
people. Without going into politics,
yes. But to quote Trump, it was
distasteful. Me personally, will I stop
listening to him? I don't know. You
know, I I memorized Juz Amma and even
Surah Baqarah with his recitations.
Subhanallah. Not not a full Surah
Baqarah before I sound too pious. I'm
you know. But the the the aim is that I
do listen to that. So subhanallah, I can
listen to somebody else. The issue is
not that. The issue is if we look at
this from an outside and be like, you
know what? I would say that was wrong.
It was absolutely wrong for you to say
that and quote this dirtbag in Epstein
files, this pedo Trump. Uh but totally
to disregard him, I don't know. I will
leave that to you guys. That's just my
two cents. I'm a nobody. And I think we
just have to be balanced with this
matter. May Allah subhana wa ta'ala deal
with all the oppressors, if they're
Iranian, Zionist,
um
Gulf countries, whatever it is. Whoever
they're oppressing, whoever's oppressing
who. May Allah subhana wa ta'ala deal
with them. Till next time.
Assalamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh.